today i'm going to tell you what the
best ide
is for programming this year in 2021.
so why would you listen to me look at
how many monitors i have
if that doesn't buy me credibility i do
not know what will
so i know what i'm talking about aside
from overspending on monitors i have
also tried out many ides
during my career as a student and a
software
engineer so before i tell you what the
best ide
is for programming let me tell you what
makes an ide
great for programming at the end of the
day it's all about how that
ide supports you in your code writing to
maximize your productivity
and your output and all that color
scheme [ __ ] programmers use to
create themselves a pathetic excuse of
an identity
and a false sense of belonging in this
not so exclusive subculture
is useless and has nothing to do with
what makes an
ide great so without further ado
the best ide for programming
is microsoft word
microsoft word has the most customizable
syntax highlighting you can get with
most ides
you can only have one color per type of
token
but here you can literally put two
different colors
in a single word not only can you change
the font color
but you can also highlight it change the
font
or for the one percent of you older
folks who watch my videos
thank you you can also increase the size
of your font for a specific piece of
code
for your vision loss so no more
discrimination in the workplace
it's time to shine my senior engineers
oh not senior engineers but like um like
seniors
who happen to be engineers so they're
not you can also hide a piece of code
for example
if you have your api key exposed you can
just
unexpose it like so all right so let's
do a little demo
let's write some python code with this
bad boy
so you start by creating a new page i'm
just going to print hello world
here you see this auto capitalization
you might think that this is an
inconvenience but it's actually great
because it simulates google's technical
interview since they make you use google
docs
to write your code so you'll get to
practice undoing all the annoying
autocorrect with this ide
okay so let's save this code for this
ide you have to save it as a plain text
file
and ms doc encoding and check this box
if you don't do that it won't work this
is a feature
not a bug it's to prevent hackers from
saving malicious code when they access
your desktop
let's run this python code now
i'll start up windows powershell because
it is the best
since microsoft is the best and anything
they make
is the best boom runs like
butter next let's write merge sort shall
we
and then customize it to our needs
save the file and run the command
boom if you don't understand merge sort
there's a merge sort video on
jomaclast.com
in the data structures and algorithms
course
we make it really easy to understand
with the intuitive animations to
visualize the algorithm
okay plugging that just made me 150
bucks
i won't go hungry today microsoft word
is only 139.99 for purchase
and you get to keep it forever i'm
definitely not sponsored by them
but if you click the link below you get
a generous one percent off your
purchase you're welcome
for the discount and for the advice to
thank me you can pay me through
paypal wire transfer or you can send me
a certified check
in the next video i let twitch chat
trade 1 000
of my money on the stock market